[Music]
hi everyone my name is Rachel Gordon and
I'm the communications and media
relations coordinator at MIT s computer
science and artificial intelligence
laboratory today I'm joined by AI and
data scientist Cameron Hamilton who
recently found love on the hugely
popular Netflix show love is blind he's
the founder of the startup AI Alliance
which focuses on tailor-made AI
solutions across all industries thanks
for joining us today thank you so much
for having me Rachel pleasure to be here
you're known mostly for your work in AI
and data science but you recently
ventured into the world of reality
television do you see a connection
between these two worlds you know that's
a good question
I think that love is blind as a special
kind of show and it's even more than a
show it's an experiment in some sense
you know it's an experiment where the
creators were interested in seeing well
if we remove as I kind of said on the
show these confounding variables of
physical appearance ethnicity race
background etc can people just make a
connection based purely on the
conversation that they've had and I
think I was drawn to the sort of
experimental setup if you will I was
intrigued by it I thought you know I
just want to see where this goes and see
you know if there's merit to doing
dating in this way interesting let's go
back to the beginning were you always
inclined towards the sciences absolutely
I always had a sense of wanting to know
how things worked and even more than
that knowing how the physical laws can
be used to create new things and I think
that's what ultimately led me to AI you
know how can we build solutions with
what we know about the world how things
work so I've also had this creative side
and I think that's where the two in
sect is you know wanting to create
something not just to understand but to
create from what we know so I understand
from your bio that you were also once a
firefighter how did you make the segue
from firefighting into AI well so
firefighting for me was a seasonal job
where you know a lot of wildfires in the
summertime and the early late spring so
I did that during college in grad school
as a way to kind of save up money for
college and also to just have some
adventures outside of academia and and
to do you know good to do something that
would be a positive thing on society so
that was kind of my side of adventure
and I think that adventurous side of me
also is what led me to do love is blind
as well
now what question or challenge were you
setting out to address when you started
your company did you feel as though
something was lacking in the field
absolutely
one thing I've seen in the field of AI
is when companies start to get bigger
they have a hard time moving course or
changing direction you know they're kind
of like a train on a track where they've
picked up a lot of momentum and they
have a hard time diverting course I
wanted to start a company that was
mobile and able to really tackle nuanced
problems that these bigger AI companies
aren't able to do and even more
specifically there are certain problems
that I wanted to address and that's why
I started my own company I wanted to be
able to work on these problems so my
biggest interest is in Parkinson's
disease I think there's a lot of room
there for implementing AI to be able to
do earlier diagnosis on the disease
potentially improve some of the
treatments that treat Parkinson's
disease such as the brain stimulation I
think there's
they're to optimize how DBS devices are
used to treat Parkinson's so those are
some of my motivations for starting
alliance AI that's great I want to talk
a little bit about digital dating now
given that algorithms are powering much
of our dating apps and the focus there
is largely on physical appearance did
your interest in the show stem from a
personal belief that perhaps looks are
overemphasized yeah so I was having that
experience myself where I was using the
apps and admittedly I was doing it in
kind of a shallow way which the apps
kind of set you up to do where you're
seeing the pictures of the person or the
all the people in the app and you're
just clicking yes or no I like them I
don't like them without really thinking
about them as a person and there's
thousands of people on these apps so
you're just kind of going through yes
and no and I what I was finding was I
was finding people who I thought were
physically attractive but when I went
out on the dates there was no real
connection there whether a shared
interest or an emotional connection so I
was just kind of running into a lot of
dating dead ends as it were so all the
more reason I wanted to try this
experiment out and see if you know
removing physical appearance could be a
positive boon do you feel that this
structure possibly shortchanges some of
the natural and biological aspects of
attraction that really only exist in a
physical space like pheromone
transmission well I think it would be
unwise to deny that physical attraction
is certainly a very very important part
of a relationship we need it frankly we
need to be physically attracted physical
intimacy is a necessity in relationship
I think that
we also need that emotional connection
as well so you know doing this
experiment it was a case where I was
able to well let me put it like this we
were able to build the emotional
connection for some obviously when they
got to see each other physically that
physical connection wasn't there so it
was a bit of a risk to do it in this
fashion but it did allow us all to focus
on building that emotional connection at
first kind of as a foundation but I
think both are needed that emotional
connection the physical connection being
aligned on values you know how are you
gonna raise children together are your
spiritual beliefs at least compatible
enough so that you're not butting heads
constantly especially if you're gonna
raise children and you know how are you
gonna manage a household together so
there's so many different things to
consider when you're finding that
lifetime partner did you entertain the
possibility of disappointment if you
weren't physically attracted to your
fiance when you first met her oh yeah of
course I mean there's in my mind there
was a very real possibility that we
wouldn't be attracted to each other
either she wouldn't wasn't gonna be
attracted to me or I wasn't gonna be
attracted to her but I thought that you
know since we have such a strong bond
before we've even seen each other if
there's less physical attraction there
that I would want I thought there might
be a possibility it could build over
time and I and I think that happens I
think that if you love someone for
reasons other than their physical
appearance you can build even such that
you're you become more physically
attracted to them I definitely agree
with that how do you see AI shaping the
future of dating we've kind of come a
long way since the first iteration of
OkCupid and
so many apps that are tailor-made to
different preferences but with all your
experiences how do you see the future of
that that's a great question so yeah I
started thinking about the current state
of dating apps and what I've seen and
what I can assume is that they're using
some variation of collaborative
filtering to underlie the algorithms
they're where you know they're rating
people and it's kind of a cold start
problem at first where the app doesn't
know the type of people that this person
is interested in and then they the app
starts to narrow down based on the
history of who they've said they liked
and didn't like but I think there's kind
of an inherent problem there where after
using the app for a period of time it
starts to narrow the scope of potential
candidates so much that you're not
exploring these people outside of that
recommended group of people who actually
may be a great complement to you or a
great match so that's that's something
that I think could be improved upon in
the future and also perhaps an app that
was able to look at a means for
incorporating the emotional component of
the relationship and finding someone
who's a match there or these other
factors that we mentioned such as you
know managing a household together
shared beliefs on family and finances
and these type of things so a more
comprehensive app that was not simply
looking at physical appearance which I
still think is very important but also
emotional connection and and shared
belief systems in these other domains as
well so there's there's just so much to
consider with a partner I think that
that's the future of dating absence is
something that's more
and after this experience on love is
blind would you recommend this format to
other people oh yeah absolutely I would
certainly recommend the love is blind
approach but with that being said I
think it's all about you as an
individual and how you go into it just
like dating in any other format there's
a certain level of openness and
vulnerability that you need to be
willing to expose yourself to so that's
the main takeaway I had was if you want
to make this work you kind of have to go
into it prepared you have to go into it
being willing to take the chance that
you may get hurt and you want to be
brave enough to expose yourself
emotionally and be willing to give it a
shot pulling back a little more
generally where do you see the future of
AI going five ten years from now whether
that's your personal goals are just more
largely Wow so the future of AI as I see
it I think it's going to diverge from
this vision that we see in science
fiction where there's some Maleficent AI
that has a mind of its own and is taking
over things I think the real positive
trajectory for AI is to think about how
a AI and human life can kind of
integrate in such a way that the AI is
only augmenting what we naturally do is
giving us a better quality of life on
the day-to-day you know whether that's
improving the way that we schedule our
day whether that's cutting down the
amount of time we spend doing sort of
minut tasks or you know basically I see
the future of AI is giving us more time
to be creative by automating tasks
allowing us to dig deeper by helping us
to do
research and helping us to be more
creative in general and and hopefully to
be able to spend more time with other
people and connect that's a really good
point well thank you so much for joining
us do you have any parting words or
advice for our viewers Wow
parting advice I would say you know if
you're worried about dating too first
kind of figure out what you want in a
partner and really to dig deep and think
you know what is it about my potential
partner that I'm gonna really need in
the long term and to be willing to be
vulnerable enough to let them know who
you really are even if they might reject
that so that's that would be my advice
and on the AI front for the general
public I would say to not be afraid of
the AI and you know the future of it I
don't think will resemble what we see in
sci-fi like the Skynet and this type of
thing that we need to start thinking
about AI in terms of how we can use it
to augment our day to day life that's
great thank you so much yes thank you
for having me